rtx 3070 ampere is back and this time
it's more affordable
we're assuming there's stock available
to purchase that is but nvidia's
availability challenges aren't really
our concern in this review it's all
about the product what it is what it
delivers the picture man video going
into this one is really simple just two
years ago rtx 2080 ti was released
raising the bar for gpu performance but
doing so at a price
1 000 of your us dollars for the most
basic of cards if you could find one rtx
3070 is apparently as fast or faster for
half the price starting at 499
bucks
a compelling proposition then and here
it is a card that has much in common
with the 3080 and 3090 we've already
looked at
but also somewhat different in key
aspects rtx 3080 blasted its ga102
silicon with 320 watts of power meaning
that although
more efficient than 2080 ti in terms of
performance per watt powered vort was
obviously rather high
very high judged by nvidia's previous
standards 30 70 tdp or tgp total
graphics power
much lower at 220 watts by extension
this means that the cooling assembly
need not be as elaborate so we have the
same design language but the dual sided
fan arrangement gives away to a more
conventional dual axial fan setup
it's also a much much smaller card than
the 3080 in fact let's take a look at a
three-way comparison between 3070 2080
ti and 3080 effectively the more power
hungry the card is the bigger it gets
and 3070 is the smallest of the bunch
with a form factor closer to the last
gen 2070 although actually it's around a
centimeter or so longer
220 watts is still more power than the
185 that the 2070 founders pulled
meaning that there is more refinement in
the cooler nvidia says that it's 16 dba
quieter than 2070 and has 44 percent
higher thermal performance in my
experience it's just as discreet as the
3080 which is to say i've got no issues
with noise on this one the design
retains the apple-like fit and finish
seen in rtx 3080 but is simpler and
lighter overall we're still using the
new nvidia design power input connector
there but only half of the pins are
actually present in the interface simply
because 3070 doesn't need any more power
you can see that with the adapter cable
you get in the box rather than taking
two standard pcie eight pin power inputs
there's just one
specs wise the new ga104 silicon
delivers
5888 cuticles up against the
2304 in the 2070. clock speeds are very
similar and the memory interface is
basically identical you get eight gigs
of gddr6 here spread out over a 256 bit
memory interface meaning 448 gigabytes
per second of throughput memory speeds
are identical as well but 7 000
megahertz perhaps more interesting is
the comparison up against 2080 ti it is
designed to match in performance terms
the cuda core has been revamped but
regardless thanks to the eight nanometer
process you're still getting more of
them in rtx 3070 clocks are a touch
higher but the 3070 has to get the job
done with a lot less memory bandwidth at
its disposal plus a reduction of 40
watts in power
now let's look at how efficient the new
card is using nvidia's pcat system here
an interposer pci express board that
also measures pcie power from the power
supply we get a fully accurate reading
of power consumption compare that to
performance in a game and essentially
you get a watts per frame metric we
measured the power and the performance
first of all in gears 5 across a range
of cards
the 3070 is the most efficient card of
the bunch 2080 ti delivers broadly
similar performance but requires 18.4
percent more power to do it 3080 and
3090 are less efficient but let's
remember the sheer amount of power
blasting through the ga102 silicon there
finally performance per watt over rx
5700 xt is hugely improved it takes the
old navi card 50 percent more power to
deliver a frame
the power efficiency metrics obviously
vary from game to game and titles that
favor amd will obviously get a better
efficiency rating and so it is with
death stranding some interesting results
here the 2080 ti founders is again
broadly similar actually it tends to be
a touch faster than 3070 as we shall
discover but it needs 22 percent more
power to deliver a frame
10 and 15 more on the power hungry 30 90
and 3080 but small navi is still some
way behind it requires 32 percent more
juice per frame big
navi really doesn't need that big
performance for what efficiency boost
that amd says it has clearly
so i said that 2080 ti is a touch faster
overall than 3070 which obviously
doesn't quite tie in with nvidia's
marketing but before we go deep on
actual performance one thing we need to
remember is that we're benching the
founders edition which actually ships
with a 19 megahertz factory overclock
and a small bump to tdp over the
reference specs so it's not quite apples
to apples but my philosophy on
benchmarking in most scenarios is that
we measure performance out of the box on
an actual product
not a set of reference specifications
so obviously this will skew the results
in favor a touch for 2080 ti but i'm
sure nvidia would have known that we'll
start with the quartet of games that
showed the biggest gains for ampere when
we looked at 3080 and 3090 and that
starts with borderlands 3 which has
become something of an unlikely standard
bearer for the new line of gpus the red
and green lines are the ones you'll be
wanting to look at here most
specifically and you'll see that despite
the 2080 ti is factory overclocked
they're pretty much on par in fact
across the whole run there is a 0.1
differential so yeah borderlands 3 holds
up to nvidia's claims interestingly
though at 1440p and 1080p there is a
touch more variance one or two points
ahead for the 2080 ti still though a
strong start for the new card going back
to 4k 3080 really shows its strength
here delivering an average of 38 percent
more performance across the run
so yeah an extra 200 for a significant
chunk of extra speed i've also included
2070 super here nvidia's last card to
sit at the 499 price point but it's a
big big increase a 46 point uplift for
the new ampere offering
of course before 2070 super there was
2070 and before that 1070 and we'll be
looking at jen on gem on jen
improvements a bit later on in this
video
control next a run-through of the game's
initial area repeatable cutscenes beyond
the intro section or pixel for pixel
matched gameplay not really possible
here and there is no benchmark so there
is a slightly larger margin for error
here but regardless again it's the red
and green lines to consider where the
2080ti founders has a small but
noticeably consistent lead over 3070 our
numbers give the 2080 ti a 1.8 lead
overall a lead that would likely be gone
if the factory overclock was removed but
yeah we're not doing that
again it's interesting to see the
grouping here the 2080ti and 3070 in the
middle 3080 well well ahead by our
reckoning we're seeing a 36 point boost
for the 3080 in this scenario likewise
though looking at the 2070 super
nvidia's last 500 card you're doing
great with 30 70. it's a 44 point uplift
on to shadow of the tomb raider then and
something interesting here a consistent
lead across the board for rtx 2080 ti up
against 30 70 here so i think at this
point it's worth pointing out that we're
talking about two cards with similar
performance profiles but where the
underlying technological makeup is very
very different 3070 has a compute
advantage but the 2080 ti has a
relatively monstrous memory bandwidth by
comparison plus the tweak over reference
clocks and speaking of clocks we clock
2080 ti founders as having a five point
lead over 30-70 and it's there or
thereabouts but in a couple of points at
1080p and 1440p as well now our focus is
on 4k in this video review but we did
bench at 1080p and 1440p2 all of those
results are in our eurogamer text review
with the fancy interactive bar charts
link in the video description below
do we turn on next and a benchmark of
two halves really in the internal
section of the bench 3070 is a bit
slower than 2080 ti in common with
everything we've seen so far and yes
remember that factory overclock once we
move outside though 2080 ti has a 9 to
10 frames per second leap which is not
insignificant at 4k now doom's ult for
nightmare textures are somehow finding
the limit of frame buffer memory
the actual visual return you get from
ult for nightmare textures is not a big
deal but it is an example of 8 gigs of
memory finding its limit at 1440p the
issue goes away but regardless there it
is now i'm going to touch on this a bit
later on
moving on to assassin's creed odyssey
and i actually found a win for the 30-70
here over 2080 ti
i mean not colossal around three percent
to the better across all three tested
resolutions 4k 1440p and 1080p
there can be some variants run to run on
this title mostly because ult for high
quality clouds a hugely taxing on the
gpu and yes more clouds means more gpu
load we aim to bench with clear skies
which does take some time
interestingly the good performance here
drops the 3080 advantage to 28
lower than the norm but yeah up against
2070 super you are getting a good 37
point slice of extra perf
again though that is lower than the
usual
so look i could carry on but i think at
this point we have a handle on what the
3070 offers and that is performance
that's going to be broadly on par with a
reference 2080 ti with the overclocked
founders card
running up to eight percent faster
now far cry 5 i noticed the 2080 ti take
a seven point lead and it is more
evident on the graphing here than in the
other titles we've looked at so far also
the case here in metro exodus where
again there's a seven point advantage
for the 2080 ti
the differential can get wider yet so
here's the miami benchmark for hitman 2
where 2080 ti founders gets its biggest
win over 30 70 at eight percent
now at the risk of repeating myself yes
the 2080 ti founders has a factory
overclock but i don't think these three
examples show performance boosts
that can be explained by the factory
overclock alone
a word now on gen on gen on gen
comparisons which is likely to be far
more relevant to proceedings than 2080
ti comparisons i suspect suffice to say
3070 versus 2070 versus 1070 comparisons
are only going to end in one conclusion
that the new ampere card annihilates its
predecessors i've also included gtx 1080
in these comparisons too because gen on
gen head to heads can be comparisons by
naming convention only when i think
pricing is just as important if not more
so
3070 launches as a 500 card just like
2070 but 1070 was just 380 dollars
pricing wise 3070 actually sits between
1070 and 1080 both of which are
represented here and either way it's no
contest board lands 3 first gtx 1070
delivers just 43
of the 30 70s output which rises to 55
with gtx 1080 yup the 1080 was a
standout gpu back in the day and now a
lower ticket price is giving you almost
twice as much performance rtx 2070 is
still a good card to this day actually
but here
well it's delivering just 61 of 3070s
performance remedies control next which
tends to set fire to older 10 series
pascal cards and here 1070 gives you
just 36 percent of the 30 70's power
rising to 43 with gtx 1080.
yeah we are benching at 4k here but
again if you look at our text review
with 1080p and 1440p metrics you'll see
that while the gap lessens at full hd it
still doesn't change too much it's still
a whitewash
2070 yes 62 of the 3070s performance
this thing is looking like a very very
nice upgrade option gen on gen and
indeed on jen
looking at shadow of the tomb raider
which dropped pace against rtx 2080 ti
if you recall well the uplifts to frame
rates are still impressive 1070 and 1080
deliver 44 and 54 of the 30 70s
performance while you're still getting a
65 leap in frame rate over rtx 2070 so
look these numbers are all looking good
those running 10 series cards will get a
vastly improved experience plus new
features like dlss and raid facing but
even 2070 owners might be looking at
this offering and considering an upgrade
as we move into a transitionary period
for gaming where extra performance is
really going to matter
rate facing performance next well with
the new rt core design in place for
ampere this is where i'd expect 3070 to
match or exceed rtx 2080 ti
founders edition factory overclock or
not so let's take a look at some results
starting with remedy's control in alex
batalia's now infamous corridor of doom
specifically chosen for favoring rt
performance in this hybrid rendered game
the result
there's a small notional win for 30 70
here but essentially it's like for like
in turn though our results show the 2070
giving just 62 of the 30 70's throughput
metro exodus with ult for class rt
global illumination i still have the
3070 failing the 2080 ti but it's within
margin of error and of course factory
overclock etc etc
perhaps not surprisingly 2070 yields 61
of the 3070s throughput
moving on quickly to battlefield 5 this
hybrid renderer is a fairly early
utilization of rate facing technology
enhanced over time but still very much
first gen 2080 ti's lead is once again
just two percent overall
but curiously 2070 fares better here
delivering 68 of the 3070s performance
level still clearly a decent upgrade
though we'll end with quake 2 rtx which
is the ultimate late faced workout in
that everything here is generated with
rt there's little to no traditional
rasterization here whatsoever there's a
3.5 percent lead for the 3070 over 2080
ti but once again
rtx 2070s coffee up 62 percent of the
3070s output
it's interesting to see that in raid
faced applications the rtx 3070's
relationship with turing cards is a lot
more stable than it is with
rasterization and i'd say puts it in a
pretty good place overall especially
since basically all new raid face titles
coming with the multiplier effect of
dlss which can produce some remarkable
results
in all cases by battlefield 5
3080 still delivers way more performance
anything up to 40 odd percent
3080 it really is a beast which leads me
on to the wrap up at
500.3070 is great value but curiously
with 3080 you're getting
extra performance pretty much in line
with the extra money you're paying but
there's something else to consider here
too which is the this price point the
card is more likely to be used for 1440p
gameplay where uh the 3080 is rather
more likely to have
some of its potential limited by the cpu
now bear in mind here that we're
actually benching with the core i9 10
900k which is the fastest gaming cpu on
the planet
for how much longer we don't know but in
the here and now it is what it is now i
do have concerns about the 30s 70s 8
gigs of memory but fewer concerns if
you're gaming at 1440p where the vram
requirement drops significantly
so yeah i'm inclined to think that what
3070 and 3080 deliver are top tier
solutions for 1440p and 2160p
respectively but clearly i mean this is
a 2080 ti class product it'll still be
pretty awesome for 4k the thing is
though these results can't be seen in a
vacuum amd's big navi may well spoil the
party but that's a discussion for
another day bottom line though rtx 3070
it is what it is rtx 2080 ti class
performance at a much cheaper price
point give or take a few percentage
points
overclocking though now i didn't put a
huge amount of time into this and i
don't profess to be any kind of
overclocking expert but on my sample
adding 150 megahertz to the core was an
insta crash but plus 100 seemed okay and
seemed to take core clocks to around
1.96 to 2.07 gigahertz here's how
borderlands 3 looks like a stock then
with plus 100 of the core and then with
plus 600 added to the g6 memory on top
of that the core overclock adds four
percent of performance with ram on top
of that taking that up to 6.4 percent
maybe with some more time and effort
better results could be possible but
suffice to say the 3080 won't be
troubled by any 30-70 anytime soon
anyway that's all for me for now like
subscribe share this is all good stuff
as is bell ringing of course
well the youtube equivalent that is
which grants you the awesome power of
instant notifications when new stuff
from df appears for your viewing
pleasure please don't forget the digital
foundry patreon supporting the team
directly is hugely important and it will
grant you pristine quality video
downloads of everything we do but that's
all from me for now thanks for making it
all the way to the end of this one if
indeed you did and just generally thanks
for watching and supporting digital
foundry